the question being asked here today is
and India become a superpower I think we
need to ask ourselves first what is a
superpower and then we are going into
economics I possibly wrong I mean I
think that's pretty obvious right now in
India we big clear in the region to some
extent of ideas and they get bigger
future in India Grove militarily I guess
you have to being at a large size
military which is considered all the
final ones in the region and when you
say in the world so what we have you had
this is a challenge of poverty that is
still legs us since independence if we
can address the needs of education and
health care of 250 million people in
India and many of them who go and get to
spend with the day I think India is well
on its way to becoming a leading nation
in the world in many different ways you
are enterprise we have innovation we
have people who have learned to lipid
diversity extreme diversity as a nation
and that Alvin strength in the nation
actually strengthens India in fact
that's a lesson that many in other parts
of the world be done as well and our
diversity in many ways is something
between i can get for they do not just
the current but for your bolts of in the
future and link in the leading nations
as many possibilities shipping